okay everybody so i am here reviewing
the
very hyped up series finale for wanda
vision
so i have a lot of thoughts obviously
just watching this
right now with you guys and yes of
course
i had tears i was crying i really
thought the
end there with vision and wanda was
really touching and it really was earned
throughout the story of the whole season
so
that also just shined really here when
vision just said so long darling there i
thought that was so
powerful and i also thought that what
really stood out to me right there at
the end was when
they show that the hex is coming in and
when wanda looks at
tommy and the camera pans up and you see
it coming and she's got to accept this
so
that was really significant also
contributes to that post-credit scene
where wanda's head is at
but i thought that was really strong and
that
really makes me feel about the whole
season how i did about this finale where
i feel like where the show's strengths
were was
in its writing about its themes and that
it had a clear vision
a crea clear structure and no pun
intended with vision
by the way but it went from wanda
having to deal with her grief of losing
vision facing it
and then recovering and then doing the
right thing in the end but
where my issue lies with the finale lies
with the season is that
this isn't me being a person who's all
pissed off because
i read all the reddit stuff i watch a
bunch of youtube videos and theories but
it is a little disappointing that agatha
was the big twist at the end of the day
of the whole season
and the problem with that is that it's a
predictable twist
i didn't really care as much as it being
predictable because i thought it would
be just be
a first twist of maybe a series of
twists and that there was something
bigger to come
but there really wasn't so that was
frustrating
and that is something you got to take
some points off because
it's predictable at the end of the day
and when you have that predictability
towards the end of a show where you have
ten episodes i mean nine episodes
it can feel like it's not this amazing
payoff of like shock value where
even throughout this finale you're
seeing where you thought it would kind
of would go
and they do a great job at it but it's
missing a little bit of that
shock factor and something that leaves
you like kind of thinking about what
just happened
that was frustrating and i think what's
going to anger a lot of people and it
kind of
angered me too is the reveal how pietro
was just this actor ralph boner
i thought that was a silly way to kind
of
justify his existence in all this and
that it was just really agnes
controlling an
actor who actually lived there uh that
was frustrating and also leads to also
that
dottie is just this woman sarah and
it was weird that they kind of put a
little more focus on her
compared to other people just throughout
the town and really didn't amount to
anything for her character so that was
kind of
strange um but
like i said the story here and the
strength of the themes is where this
show really shined and did a hell of a
job i think it was so
powerful that when finally the hex is
gone
and you see that wanda is just standing
in the home that her and vision were
supposed to be in
that really really hit home i also
love that they showed last episode
literally wanda seeing at a time
in the mind stone the vision of her
scarlet witch way back when which is
awesome that we actually saw that this
episode and i think
she really needed a new get up and a
refresh
and it is an awesome look i love how the
whole scarlet witch costume
works i also think it's important to
note
that it is that magneto red so
i don't count out that they'll somehow
twist her
origin story around a bit to kind of fit
it that maybe
she was originally of magneto's child
and then these new parents
took her in you can always work around
it to bring him in but that's also a
disappointment that
knowing that scarlet witch is their
connection to go towards
this x-men story they're eventually
going to go to with now this movie being
announced the mutants
it's surprising there wasn't anything in
the post credits at least
connecting towards x-men uh that was a
little
strange but i think that
it's interesting because i think a lot
of people were surprised too that the
kids
were also not actually real
so that was interesting too i don't know
how i feel about that
but i think that it's going to be
interesting where this goes now
and what they do with wanda in the mcu
she's clearly being set up now is
really a main person in this whole canon
and if you look at the whole season it
is a great
real origin story for the next chapter
of mcu
and really an origin to put scarlet
witch
in the center here and her significance
because really
she was always kind of a side player in
the avengers and now she's really coming
to the front
and what i love about her character
is that i'm gonna compare it to captain
marvel because
the problem i have with captain marvel
as an example of a superhero i don't
think the mcu did well is that
she has no flaws right she's not someone
you connect to why
is wanda so much more popular already
just from the show than captain marvel
ever was is because people can relate to
the grief and trauma she has they're
making her an actual person you would
meet
in real life and not just a perfect
robot
like captain marvel so that's where also
if you look at the mid credits scene
again we all know that monica rambo's
gonna be in captain marvel too
so that wasn't the most exciting thing
it's cool that
taylors and cree want her to come up
there but okay
sure and monica rambo wasn't really
anything great in this finale either it
was kind of strange like her whole point
was just that one
scene to protect the kids and that was
really it um and then
with the second post-credits scene
obviously leading into now
where we know that scarlet witch is
going to be in the multiverse of madness
doctor strange too
it's interesting because her in that
very
doctor strange like stance but embracing
now
all this dark magic she actually is
learning about herself and knows and
that witch hood
that she's still thinking about those
kids and that's gonna be a stain on her
forever like
how do you forget that how do you just
let go of kids you create you
attach to so that's going to be
interesting and it's going to
always be that thing i think that's
pulling wanda and tempted to go
to that darkness and just screw
everything and get her kids back so that
i like they set that up for her
character
and like i said i love the getup but i
love too about this finale is that
they really leaned into the witch part
of scarlet witch and
her embracing her witchhood and that
whole story
with agatha and i love that whole
sequence where agatha kind of
spins it on her and all the witches are
pointing at
wanda so that really worked well for me
and
with the vision being now that he's
transferring the information
this created vision by scarlet witch is
transferring information to the white
vision
is interesting so you know mcu man no
one actually ever really dies so
we're gonna see vision again but in this
new form so at least it's a refresh form
the white vision was really cool um i
think it's gonna be
where they go with that but they didn't
sacrifice
again the theme of the show about grief
and
facing it and accepting it and again
they put theme first which i appreciate
to put character first which i also
appreciate
and again as a finale and as a whole
season though
when we go to the excitement factor and
where there might be a needed twist or
something that was a little bit more
unpredictable happening that didn't
really land here again agatha being the
main twist of this all and that ph was
just an actor and that
you know uh dottie is just sarah it's a
problem i've seen a lot of shows
recently where i hope
show creators can understand that
audiences are
really really smart now and that's
because we watch so much damn tv
and we want more we want more for our
time and
there will be people that would defend
it and like whoa that's your fault and
like
you know it's it's silly the cool thing
twist is that there is no twist and that
you just over thought it
i'm not asking for a crazy reveal like
mephisto or magneto
flying down that would be awesome but no
i'm just asking for
you need to have things though that
shock people and throw people off that
make us feel like we're using our brain
a little more and i feel like that's
where the show kind of missed the mark
where in the beginning
you felt that it was setting up for
something that was making you use your
brain and try to figure everything out i
think that's why everyone got so excited
but when you don't pay it off that way
and it's just
more cut and dry brings it back down to
what most of these mcu projects are like
where it's just
solid but they didn't really go to where
the the ceiling was for this show that's
my biggest
disappointment of it all but having said
that
awesome acting all around the production
design is incredible the effort put into
every episode
with all the easter eggs really really
just amazing the music and in particular
catherine hahn was incredible as agatha
harkness and
elizabeth olsen just killed it
especially in this finale i thought in
particular
the scene where she's realizing what
she's done
to all these people and they all start
coming after her and then her snapping i
thought that was the best acting i've
actually ever seen elizabeth olsen do so
really props to her and like i said in
the beginning
we really need to consider emmys for
people even in superhero shows and that
starts here with elizabeth olsen
it's just incredible acting and all the
different characters she played
and different emotional beats so she
should totally be praised for that
and i do think it was smart that this
show decided
not to really make this a two-hander
having it be
vision and wanda with equal screen time
or focusing
both their stories in here it really was
wanda's show
and vision was a part of her story so i
think it was smart they didn't let it
get too muddy with that um
but overall i'm gonna give this episode
a 9.1
it wasn't my favorite of the season i
think the best two episodes of the
season
were in the middle there episode four
and five i think that's what really hit
its stride but because
after the agatha reveal you kind of just
knew it was coming and it
finished that way so that's where you
lose a little bit of the excitement here
and i think a lot of people are going to
be
a little frustrated with that but
overall as a season i'm also going to
give it a 9.1
really solid didn't hit the ceiling i
think it could have but
it's actually such an exciting great
experience i enjoyed watching it fully
and
it being the first mcu show we're seeing
i'm in
i trust them with it i feel like i
didn't waste my time and i
enjoyed watching of this character wanda
transform
and grow and i think that it makes me
more excited for the shows to come
with falcon and winter soldier and loki
and much more and how they're gonna do
this
next phase of marvel so let me know down
below what you thought of this episode
but also what you thought of the season
as a whole i love to hear your thoughts
i read every comment try to respond as
many as i can please make sure to
subscribe if you haven't already
it really helps me in so many ways you
have no idea and i'll be doing other
marvel shows as well coming up
100 loki not sure yet about winter
soldier and